hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay now
what are we going get a box here oh I
know what to do with this box
besides row it with my incredible
strength there's a vent up there yeah
yeah see uh yeah pwnage oh those look
like breakable boxes Bob yeah bunk no
bunk
uh uh bunk miss bunk yeah I think I
destroy everything inside it if I do a
hammer this hard Oh showed up my brute
strength oh yeah I'm so great all right
was that it oh okay all right those is a
goody room oh I'm over 50 health 50 L
for the longest time okay but that's not
the reason I came up here what up okay
ah get back here no no there's a
detonator somewhere wha what I give up
Oh should I should I switch out the
shotgun for a machine pistol no I've got
two pistols it's not like I need more
bullets I need stopping power but this
has no range that's also true I'll give
it a try it's a new weapon I'm sure I'll
find other shotguns later and if not I
can come back
okay I did not find the detonator
sit up maybe if I go up
aha there it is I see it got you babe
yeah oh yeah oh that blew it up I I
expected to bring it down with me but
okay kaboom
ah so bright so sunshiny hmm so pleasant
I'm sure that's all going to change but
Danny by me nope goodbye
once again my computer's not handling
we're okay I got to go in the water oh
boy oh hello get some air
this looks familiar it really is amazing
the modifications that this team made to
the cry fear her to the half-life engine
for cry of fear because if you think
about it cry fear was like really really
really it looks good for a half-life 1
mod I mean just compare it to this even
though the water is moving which is
pretty cool anyway hello okay that that
dough gets more air I don't know how
long I can all my breath I don't have an
HEV suit to let me know
no going again
no get open the door door don't screw
with me door hello Golden Gate why has
this place underwater anyway oops
OOP aha err Oh what's up ah huh huh huh
it's like one of those tentacle thingies
don't look straight up those strange
holes that's a good rule to live life by
don't look up strange holes Hey Hey Oh
another one oh there I need to find a
ladder yeah Oh No hello there's
something over there
can I get it rip oh I thought I had that
no oh it's not breakable man let me try
one more running jump at it Cup huh oops
I was early I have I went off a little
early
oh it's embarrassing looks good
I never go off early what not you again
go away I got barrels bro yeah can it
come this way
ah there we are barrels oh I get it ah
ah
I use these barrels to float my way over
to the other one
hmm interesting but first I got to take
care of this guy hold your head still
Hotel up there oh yeah hmm oh yeah yeah
okay
now get out of the way we got barrels to
move whoosh gasp ah there we go no oh
god damn it
yeah what another one boom boom and boom
yeah give me one more
boom yeah back yeah ah another one ha
missed missed again
what Dow how's bull honky all right this
should be enough right maybe up get away
boom boom no not yet boom that's not
what I needed
get off get off alright whatever
Here I am I probably could if I hadn't
nailed the jump timing I probably could
have whacked this and gotten in here get
a little game breaking nothing new for
me hello
hello okay that's that's where I was all
right Oh button ah hello man the people
who make this game really love making
you go around the same level oh no not
today you're gonna get face full of ah
damn it
machine gun there we go that's a pretty
powerful machine gun huh no no nope nope
nope three of you holy hell
okay got two three yes perfect perfect
hope no one look no if you're if you're
not a if you're not over eighteen don't
look don't look at these awesome
posters don't look at them don't
whatever you do don't look at these
don't look at them seriously I'm not
joking don't look at them don't look at
these posters don't look at them
yeah okay anyway
was there something else Oh sports get
in here besides these posters no okay
all right that's enough of that um um
keep sitting black marks on the ground I
think they're like clips or something ah
this is the door that was blocked from
the other side and the other side door
that was blocked from the other thigh is
over here ha yep okay making my way
making progress ha monsters huh oh hello
Oh
get darker huh why huh wha No Oh see
another subway huh huh oh I see you ah
what hey you first-timer oh I see I see
what happened as you gotta get out of
here
ah Oh No why are there so many of you oh
my god oh my god I guess you got I gotta
get outta here I gotta get I gotta get
out of here I gotta get out okay I'll go
to the right now and if we can you ah ah
okay
I'm gonna have to do a little game
breaking I think I know what I need to
do
oh no no I can't cuz that closes up oh
how the heck am I supposed to survive
this
ah
ah hammer yeah missing yeah okay maybe
if I camp in this doorway
nothing can hit me
oh my god can nothing hit me ah
something hit me oh my God look how many
of them there are
how the hell oh is that a button I might
be a button still how the hell I mean oh
my god
[ __ ] huh okay yes it's a button to
button there buttons there are buttons I
got my help
okay there are buttons but holy hell
it's like too many of them too many of
them
too many of them too many too many too
many oh my goodness oh my goodness I got
to think about this there was no safe
spot there's no place to exploit I don't
have enough bullets for all of them
that's almost impossible to get around
them this is the first one ran out of
bullets no okay
oh man gotta be something I could do
something about maybe maybe I can get in
tighter
nope that's not gonna work this would be
fine if the ones behind me working to
kill me like that
oh man okay yeah
okay that's - I killed mayor's to kill
two of them Wow there's just oh this is
full-on pwnage there any way I can hop
on one of their heads that would be
ideal
maybe if I constantly jus come somehow
I just chew gum no but don't have enough
bullets dodge Dodge Pro dodge dammit
okay I just got to focus on trying to
get to the buttons okay kill these first
they're the first or miss every single
round every round is good that's good
too oh [ __ ] me
bro bro can't get me a mic owner can't
give me my corner can't give me my
corner ah I don't want to I don't want
to I don't wanna I don't wanna I don't I
don't wanna I don't wanna oh man
this is brutal brutal brutal brutal wish
I had my shotgun because my shotgun had
more ammo we said I might have a
fighting chance but right now it's like
not even close
ah ah damn it
ah man
corner no corner don't work [ __ ] hell
oh man this is terrible
okay well nice try
yeah I'm away [ __ ] you [ __ ] off I got a
freaking button and then frigging
frigging frack bric-a-brac freaky frack
free game prac shake n bake nope okay oh
man okay I'm gonna think about this
around the time I'm gonna think about
what am I do here because oh man I don't
know it seems daunting to say the least
unless I'm missing something but anyway
I'll figure it out so thank you guys so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next part
bye bye